my life was perfect until you stole it
it wouldn't be a stretch to say that
if any descendant's character was
wrought into the core it'd be princess
audrey
disney's the descendants franchise has
turned the tables when it comes to
the traditional concept of heroes and
villains and we're pretty sure a fourth
part would definitely follow in those
same footsteps
especially when it comes to dealing with
princess audrey
have you been doubting this anti-hero's
rise back to the good side well
you're not alone
audrey has never been the nicest person
and her quick rendezvous with
maleficent's power
totally proved that this girl has more
bad in her than we probably even know
so what exactly would audrey's future
look like in a descendant's four
will she ever get a happy ending like
her former classmates or will she be the
queen of mean
forever it's time for a little payback
audrey definitely made up for lost time
in the descendants 3 after not appearing
in the second film at all
and the creators took advantage of her
reappearance in fact
them making their classic mean girl an
actual villain is
actually kind of ironic and hilarious
imagine actual mean girl regina george
suddenly growing purple hair and cursing
everyone in sight
people would pay to see that anyway the
point is that even before audrey
embraced maleficent's powers and became
the queen of mean her intentions were
never good
in fact the reason she got herself into
the whole ordeal in the first place was
because she was planning on destroying
the royal crown
so why should we be so sure that she
would not continue her revenge on mal
and the rest of the villain's kids in a
potential fourth film
how long does she think that's gonna
last now it's just the bad girl
infatuation
she spent the entire first movie
terrorizing mal and making fun of her
for having a crush on ben
and just being maleficent's daughter in
general some might sympathize that she
had everything taken away from her
but karma was definitely laughing
somewhere in the corner and at the end
of the first film she might have made up
with mal and danced her way gracefully
into the sunset with the rest of the
gang
but her reaction to mal and ben's
engagement in the beginning of the third
film
really showed that she still hated mal
with a passion
you spell ben to destroy all of auradon
i mean you can't really get much more
bitter than that
right wrong she totally took her
jealousy to the next level
so if she's faked being on good terms
with mal and the villain's kids before
who says that she did not do the same at
the end of the third film
the truth is we're just not buying her
whole i'm so thankful you saved me i'll
never do it again vibe
does anyone else think that she grasped
onto the evil persona rather
quickly not to mention that she seemed
to really like being the queen of mean
she was straight vibin don't agree with
us hey that's cool
but you might want to believe the
actress who played audrey
sarah jeffrey just like we are tv line
was very interested to hear just what
she thought of audrey's evilness
and whether or not it existed without
her being possessed
sarah did not hold back in fact she
admitted that
good can't exist in bad and bad can't
exist in good
she also warned that when it comes to
audrey's character
it's not black and white so all in all
we're pretty confident that getting her
revenge on mal
ben and the rest of the villain kids is
actually a smart way to incorporate a
descendant's four into the franchise
i mean audrey can't be happy that magic
is allowed on the isle of the lost now
especially if she is still holding on to
the remnants of her perfect life before
mal
what do you think about the possibility
that audrey is still evil
do you think that she's still holding on
to her grudge against mal and the rest
of the villain's kids
we don't know about you but if someone
took away our potential happy ending
our grudge wouldn't just fade just
because we were possessed by the powers
of maleficent
as we all know the world of the
descendants is not just full of fairy
tale happy endings
in fact it's very possible that audrey's
classic happy ending is at stake
especially if we consider this option
for a part 4 of the franchise
while the films have given us plenty of
villains to ponder over in this universe
there are still many that have been left
out and others whose stories don't seem
to be quite finished
so what are the odds that audrey might
team up with a villain in the future in
order to fulfill her evil motives
against mal and ben we're saying that
they're pretty good
in fact the descendants 3 left a lot of
easter eggs that fully support audrey's
queen of mean persona
actually turning into a queen of mean
squad you'll forgive me
i don't think so we all love to hate
captain hook's son harry hook but deep
down
we all know that we probably date him in
a second if he asked so can we
really blame audrey for that little cute
meeting they had at the end of the last
film
you might think that saying audrey
grabbing him as her dance partner
and him eyeing her means that they'll be
forming a team evil as a stretch but
is it rule of thumb usually is that
everything in a film happens for a
reason
we know we know you're probably saying
but harry is totally in love with uma
and while we totally agree with you we
also think that hook jr would also do
anything in his power to get the
treasure he has his eyes on
so if dating audrey is the way to do
that it's totally plausible
we can even take it a step further and
say that maybe audrey
teams up with the entire crew while they
did help out mal in the descendants 3
and ended up on good terms we've learned
that anything is possible when it comes
to the villains kids
especially when it comes to them being
influenced by their evil parents
so who knows it would be an interesting
concept to show that
not only the villains kids are
susceptible to becoming evil
evil can truly be found in everyone
speaking of audrey's teaming up with
villains did everyone forget about
maleficent and her goals
could the descendants 3 totally been an
entire foreshadow of what's to come in
part 4
or even a spin-off the whole plot of
audrey stealing a magic wand in order to
get revenge is basically maleficent's
plan from the first film
just a different wand not to mention
audrey literally took on maleficent's
magic
could audrey be the daughter maleficent
was always looking for
could a potential maleficent return mean
a team up with audrey
maleficent no doubt wants to take down
her daughter after everything that's
happened
meaning they also have a common goal
that would cross out audrey's happy
ending for sure
just picture it the queen of mean and
maleficent crashing the royal wedding
between
mal and ben
iconic if you're into that sort of thing
we can already see the fairy godmother's
shocked face now and uh we're kind of
here for it like we touched on before
the villains now being able to cross
over into auradon freely
not to mention use their magic is no
doubt going to come with consequences
and just how will those consequences
affect audrey or maybe it'll benefit her
we'll just have to wait and see so
taking all these theories into
consideration
what are the actual odds that we'll be
getting a part 4 or spin-off in the
future
well we dug even deeper into some
behind-the-scenes info
and we're going to say it's pretty safe
to keep hope alive while there was
definitely some doubt around another
installment after the tragic loss of
cameron boyce back in 2019
the cast has since stepped forward to
dish everything they know about a
possible continuation
in an interview with et online star dove
cameron says that she understandably
doesn't love the idea of doing it
without cameron but that another
installment is definitely not out of the
question
in fact she mentioned that the next part
will probably continue on in a different
incarnation
a spin-off maybe more specifically an
audrey spin-off it would explain why the
last descendants movie was very audrey
focused
the creators are potentially not
finished telling the story of her
character art
sarah herself spoke about how audrey
would move forward in another part
she says she feels like descendants 4
could totally happen
but also a spin-off could happen she
even went into detail describing what
she thinks that spin-off could look like
she gushed that the spin-off could
include new characters and new daughters
and sons of princesses and princes and
other villains
finishing off with the fact that with
the descendants there are truly endless
possibilities
when it came to how audrey would fit in
she said that moving forward
audrey definitely has a lot of damage
control to do after her past
actions so it seems like even sarah is
certain that audrey's queen of mean days
aren't exactly behind her
it's funny that sarah mentioned a new
generation of fairy tale characters
because that could totally fit in with
her story perfectly
remember our theory about how audrey is
still not over her grudge
well what if that carries on into the
next generation
if audrey and harry or any other villain
end up having children
they could potentially still carry the
hate their mother did for mal and ben's
children
it's basically the descendants 3.0 and
we'd get to see our favorite characters
kids i mean can you imagine evie and
doug's children
adorable the spin-off could also include
characters like dizzy and celia
we may or may not be getting a little
too excited about the possibilities
all in all this type of spin-off is
right up the descendants franchise alley
it is after all basically the plot of
the first film
but isn't every reboot like that hey
we're not complaining
what is wrong with you people so maybe
audrey still has a lot of development to
do when it comes to dealing with the bad
parts of herself
but will all of this prevent her happy
ending or can villains still get those
we've seen mal overcome the evil that
she thought she inherited
but was she ever truly evil like audrey
seems to be
maybe audrey's happy ending is embracing
her evil and disney will surprise us
with yet another twist
it would definitely show how complicated
humans are when it comes to moral
compasses
or maybe she'll stay as the anti-hero
not quite the villain but not
quite saving the day type either could
her true home happy ending possibly be
waiting on the isle of the lost
instead of auradon either way an
iteration of the descendants involving
audrey is no doubt going to be
entertaining were you expecting someone
else
do you think that she'll eventually get
the fairy tale or is she too set on
revenge
what about her apology do you think that
she's back to the good side for good
what could a potential sequel look like
for this princess
let us know all your villainous thoughts
in the comments section below oh and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a big thumbs
up